[Musique]
partant de là
ça
[Musique]
là
on
moi
[Musique]
à
on est on est déjà devenue demandé qu'on
nous respecte un petit peu parce qu'on
se fait démolir on a rarement une
profession qui se fait démolir autant
depuis un an ou deux
on critique tout ce qu on fait quoi
finalement on essaye de faire au mieux
avec les moyens qu'on nous donne
on a un gouvernement qui nous endorment
qui nous remet des normes à tour de bras
et on s'aperçoit que les gens
un manche des choses à apporter qui sont
produites près sur les mêmes bases donc
déjà moi je sais pas quelle est la
consigne syndicale 1 mais moi ce que
j'en pense c'est qu'il faudrait déjà
qu'on soit sur un pied d'égalité là
dessus toi
[Musique]
maman
le climat chaud thing face a choisi la
bonne image aux côtés des rebelles je
pense que face à ce choc est violent
[Musique]